foreign
today's question comes from Clark in
Chicago Clark writes things have been
tight for us financially this year and
we haven't been able to buy the big
gifts we are hoping to get for our kids
how can we navigate any possible
meltdowns from the kids that might come
from being disappointed by not getting
what they had been hoping for
oh man
Dave this is this question change by age
um yes and it also changes by
um how far Upstream you want to get so
this is kind of like somebody asking
hey we're down by 32 runs in the bottom
of the ninth how do we win this game
well you're probably not going to win
this one because you're down by 32. and
you waited till the ninth inning too and
you suck at baseball well I wouldn't go
that far but but but you're right so I
uh in our house Sheila and I my wife
decided we're not doing a bunch of crazy
big gifts this year
um we're gonna do an experience and so
we started prepping the kids months out
Christmas is going to look and feel
differently this year we also reached
out to we have the only grandkids so I
got a real generous sister and brother
and sister-in-law and my parents and
they love to shower and we said hey this
year we're going smaller so we started
conversations on the front end and we've
started inviting our kids into more
giving things so they can see with their
own eyes and touch their own hands
people who are go without during
Christmas and so we started a
preparation for this moment a long time
ago
if we had just waited until Christmas
day and they wake up and they run down
there and there's no that's gonna be
tough and they're kids and let them if
kids get their feelings here it doesn't
bother me because they're little kids if
they're
9 10 11 12 13 on up that's when you can
start having different conversations but
man it's Christmas morning this is a
little bit late in the game to be having
this kind of conversation
it sounds more like
the I mean the kid's gonna do what kids
are gonna do
it feels like Clark feels like less of a
father because he's not able to buy the
things that make him feel good that he's
able to give to his kids and I think
Clark and his wife need to look in the
mirror and recognize they busted their
butt this year it was a tough year it
was a hard year and they provided for
those kids and they did a really good
job
yeah um in order to
let yourself off the hook you and your
wife sit down and try to name the big
gift that you got when you were a kid
on any Christmas
you probably don't remember a single one
if you remember one that might be good
if you remember two that's unusually
good doubt real seriously you remember
five Christmas gifts from five different
years
I remember one
I think I could probably come up one or
two yeah it was probably the same
Christmas I was having to dodge
dinosaurs because it was a long time ago
but um we got a stone wheel that's it I
got a wheel I got this new thing called
fire we got fire
um no the uh uh
so I guess my point is that they'll live
through it yes they will
um and uh the bigger deal you make about
it the bigger deal there's gonna be
right
um but I do think that
um it's also the secret I use playing
golf
um the secret to happiness is low
expectations
yes exactly let's lower their little
expectations and some methodology age
appropriately
um if it's a 16 year old that's a
completely different discussion on
lowering expectations than if it's a
four-year-old and with a 16 year old you
say hey it's been a tough year and I
just want you to know coming out of the
gate there's going to be fewer prices
it's just going to be a little slim it's
getting me tough just get your little
butt ready but with the younger ones if
you have younger ones you can say hey
Santa sent a letter
and said it's been tough times so
there's gonna be fewer gifts this year
but I want to provide you more time to
spend together set up a tent in your
living room and y'all have a camp out do
something fun he said he loves you extra
special and whatever and I'll remember
that forever all that's good and so you
can create experiences and
um you know marshmallows still stuck in
the carpet four months later I don't
know whatever but um there's all kinds
of stuff you can do here that's not
um doesn't come out of a box because
we've all had the experience those of us
with a few years uh on us of the child
um it's three playing in the Box more
than playing with the item that came in
the Box
very distressing for the parent that
bought that thing from Neiman Marcus but
yeah
um so yeah that's so there is a even as
a grandfather I will admit
Um Papa Dave suffers from I am enjoying
this more than they're going to oh dude
I do too man that's one of my favorite
things in the world I'm let down that my
children have all told me I have to stop
overdoing it so it's it's it's just
ruined Christmas for me I'm just saying
but
um not so I mean that's the thing so I
think Brad
um you know Clark Clark
this is from Clark
wait a minute Christmas vacation just
emailed us right here on the Ramsey Show
well tile Cousin Eddie we said hey Clark
um wow
and that you're not getting the bonus
from your Amino ball show no pool
no pool man that's not coming sorry but
I just think this is did you guys do
this no you really didn't do it oh my
God
you guys are pranking Us in there this
is not this is real it's a form so
whoever did it might have been being
cute oh it just can't it yeah
yeah but I don't I don't think Christmas
Vacation had a location did they was it
Chicago
some of you tweet in or email in let us
know because I don't know but uh trivia
for Christmas all right so I did want to
talk about this so sidebar turn a little
bit of an angle off of this
um
because I've got Dr John deloney here
own your past change your future 100
percent
of
adults that go and visit other adults
called their relatives at Christmas
bring some form of boundary issue some
form of uh
heavy to light trauma some form of uh
negative or positive memory
expanded in our brains to these these
singular Day events around Christmas
yeah and and speaking of setting
expectations and being grown-ups during
the holidays talk about navigating
family crap
that is in your own brain and is in
their brains and boundaries through
these holidays what are some basic ideas
or rules that well the strange thing I
experience is I and I wish there was a
less way of saying this
but I feel like my body becomes 14 again
I feel like I become a kid and I
instantly fall into I'm a middle child
and I've got an older sibling and a
younger sibling I feel like I just get
in this weird and I have to remind
myself wait a minute I got grown kids in
a house like and a wife I'm not 14
anymore and so hey I have to be
cognizant of myself what we did this
year what Sheila and I have done the
last few years is we send an email out
to the family and here's when we're
gonna be able to come here's what we
want to do here's some things that we
think will be fun anything y'all are
interested in doing and we like to do is
have those conversations the best we can
and our family works best in writing
before we get yeah but I mean when I get
there
I the years that I did not
pre think about perception and I'm not
14 I'm not the broke kid that came home
with your daughter and you didn't want
her to yeah marry and I didn't blame him
later but um I wouldn't let one one
would not have wanted my daughter to
marry the guy that came home with her
when it was me
um so either so I get that they weren't
mean about it um and they're still not
mean about it but
um the um I'm not that guy I have to
reset my mind intentionally before I bow
in the driveway that's right there's
some pre-planning relationally
psychologically you kind of have to do
otherwise you do fall right into that
hole don't you you do and I I start
getting sharp with people I start eating
too much so on the junk food table to
make myself feel a little bit better
um people will grab more drinks so I
think it's about knowing all I can
control in the situation is me and if
you want to poke some fun at me and have
some fun I'm Not Gonna Take It Personal
I'm not gonna push back I'm gonna smile
or I'm gonna take myself out of this
situation and that's really the two
options again I'm not discussing Trump
no and I'm not discussing covered they
said you were not going to change
anybody's house birthday
[Laughter]